Speaker 1: . I want the 2024 Republican
primary to become the dirtiest, filthiest,
most corrupt and disgusting mudslinging fest
that we can imagine because it will be bad for
Republicans in 2024. And we already read of
Trump going after Ron DeSantis as being fat
and phony and whiny. But Ron DeSantis is also
now going after Donald Trump. There's a great
article by Gabriel Sherman in Vanity Fair. Gabriel
Sherman is very good at these types of articles.
The article is called The Ron DeSantis The Making
and Remaking and Remaking of a MAGA Air with the
subtitle The Florida Governor is the Fox lobbying
lib owning successor in waiting to Donald Trump's
Cult of personality. But for all the Santos's
bona fides and rocketing national profile,
doubts about his own persona calculated, aloof,
cold blooded persist. Is it any wonder he and the
former president are already locked in a 2024 Cold
War? The article explains that behind the scenes,
Ron DeSantis is not a big fan of
Donald Trump. And I have to tell you,
Ron DeSantis is not a dumb guy. I think Ron
DeSantis is completely depraved, morally,
ethically, and his willingness to take on the
persona that he has taken on as Florida governor
rubs me obviously the wrong way. I think it's
immoral and disgusting. But the truth is, DeSantis
is not stupid. He's a highly educated guy, and
it's hard to believe that DeSantis would genuinely
see Trump in a positive light. Obviously,
DeSantis sees Trump as a moron, and that is
exactly what this article says the scientists
are saying behind the scenes. The article says,
So far, the DeSantis Trump smack down has been
unfolding off camera, but it likely won't stay
that way. DeSantis in private, trashes Trump.
He calls him a TV personality and a moron who
has no business running for president, a former
DeSantis staffer said. DeSantis tells donors that
if he takes on Trump, he would launch a full
frontal attack on his record and competence,
according to a Republican source briefed on the
conversation. DeSantis says the only way to beat
Trump is to attack him head on. He would. He says
he would turn to Trump during a debate and say,
Why didn't you fire Fauci? You said you would
build the wall, but there is no wall. Why is that?
this.And this is not stupid. My interest is
that both of these guys go down in flames
in 2024. So I say Let them fight. I've
been saying this for a while. The more
Trump hurts the Santos, the better. The more
DeSantis hurts Trump, the better. At some point,
one of these two is going to be the frontrunner.
And whatever hits they take from the other guy are
going to extend the Republican primary, make it
uglier, and hopefully turn people off of voting
for voting for Republicans altogether. DeSantis
has taken a lead in the betting markets. These
are extraordinary numbers. Now, I want to remind
everybody, this is not polling of who do you
support? This is betting. Who do you believe will
eventually be the nominee? DeSantis is now leading
Trump. This has not been the case for a while. And
in fact, if we look at the 90 day let's see what
are the numbers here? Uh, yes. You see that some
time in early to mid-August, DeSantis equaled and
then surpassed Trump. Trump sort of came back
a little bit, but now it is DeSantis steadily
in the lead in the betting markets. If you want to
make a dollar betting on Trump being the nominee,
you've got to bet $0.29. And if you want to make
a dollar betting on DeSantis being the nominee,
you've got to bet $0.35. In other words, since
it is considered more likely at this point in the
betting market that DeSantis will be the nominee.
You've got to put up more money to make a dollar.
This is a really big deal. The sand, this is
building a lead here now in terms of the behind
the scenes. If I were DeSantis, I would be trying
to, for example, maybe expedite the investigations
into Trump, into Sanders's own state of Florida.
Remember Mar a Lago? Trump's home is in Florida.
I would be trying to secretly screw Trump over by
making the legal trouble as bad as possible. Now,
maybe DeSantis is doing that, but you have
the Republican Party having to walk what
is essentially a tightrope. They can't
turn on Trump right now without losing
Trump supporters. And it's too early for that
because Trump may indeed run. At the same time,
if they're too aligned with Trump, they risk going
down with the ship. If Trump indeed gets indicted
and goes down and someone like the Santos really
builds an actual polling lead against Trump. Many
of these presidential elections, even though the
electorate, the popular vote difference is big,
I mean, millions and millions of votes that Joe
Biden won by in 2020. Oftentimes the electoral
margin comes from narrow victories in just a
handful or even two or three states. So it is a
very fine line that these Republicans are walking.
My view as a concerned leftist is let them fight,
let them fight and let them
make it as filthy as possible.